[Musique]
tête haute nous chantons goulili allard
qui est ma poule et tout nu se tombe où
il ya la rue riquet même
m
je lis mots
juliette gréco c'était une voix profonde
et sensuelle une interprète à la
gestuelle unique à la fin de la seconde
guerre mondiale julien grillon fait
partie de cette jeunesse qui fait la
fête dans le quartier parisien saint
germain des prés la jeune femme
deviendra l'égérie de ce mouvement
appelé l'existentialisme et à saint
germain
on avait faim on avait soif on dormait
pas on se faisait bien on était libre
c'est jean paul sartre qui l'a poussé
vers la chanson en 1949 l'ordre elle
interprète d'abord des poèmes lisant
chanson pour elle tout le pen tout
chanteur défunt c'est ainsi que le
public découvre sur scène une chanteuse
expressive toute vêtue de noir et blanc
endo sartre lui fait alors cadeau de sa
première chanson la rue des blancs
manteaux suivront vian ferry prévert
aznavour brel brassens béart et
gainsbourg juliette gréco est séduisante
provocatrice est à la fois garçon manqué
je vivais libre je visais thèmes comme
vives et les hommes et les way
et xavier mois elle fréquente le
trompettiste miles davis et le
producteur américain darryl zanuck en
1988 elle épouse son pianiste et
compositeur gérard jouannet sa carrière
est ponctué de rôles au théâtre à la
télévision et au cinéma où elle
travaille avec john huston et houston -
toutefois chanter demeure ce qu'elle
préfère la chanson on permet de jouer la
comédie
la chanson permet de rencontrer des gens
amoureuse de sa langue elle chante
toujours en français qu'elle soit à
paris au japon ou en grande bretagne
[Musique]
deux morts puis revoir
juliette gréco se produit à de
nombreuses reprises au québec
elle fait un arrêt aux francofolies à
l'été 2015 à l'occasion de sa dernière
tournée intitulée merci mais un avc subi
en mars 2016 la force à suspendre ses
activités sous le ciel dans paris march
[Musique]
aujourd'hui la jolie môme n'est plus
mais elle demeurera une icône de la
chanson française sous le pont de bercy
ici valérie michaela bayne radio canada
montréal si de musiciens elle que un
badugi les gens par milliers